dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I hear hmm you are
in for a real treat today because today
we are not going to simulate just plain
regular fluids no we're going to
simulate ferrofluids these are fluids
that have magnetic properties and
respond to an external magnetic field
and you will see in a moment that they
are able to even climb things you see in
the reference footage here that this
also means if there is no magnetic field
we have a regular fluid simulation
nothing too crazy here
in this real-world footage we have a
tray of ferrofluid up in the air and we
have a magnet below it so as the tray
descends down and gets closer to the
magnet this happens
the strength of the magnetic field is
not the only factor that a simulation
needs to take into account here's
another real experiment that shows that
the orientation of the magnet also makes
a great deal of difference to the
distortions of the fluid surface
and now let's have a look at some
simulations this simulation reproduces
the rotating magnet experiment that
you've seen in a second ago it works
great what is even more if we are in a
simulation we can finally do things that
would either be expensive or impossible
in the real life so let's do exactly
that you see a steel sphere attracting
the ferrofluid here
and now the strength of the magnet
within is decreased giving us the
impression that we can bend this fluid
to our will how cool is that
in the simulation we can also experiment
with arbitrarily shaped magnets
and here's the legendary really
experiment where with magnetism we can
make a ferrofluid climb up on the steel
helix look at that when I first seen
this video and started reading the paper
I was just giggling like a little girl
so good just imagine how hard it is to
do something where we have footage from
the real world that keeps judging our
simulation results and we are only done
when there's a near exact match such as
the one you see here huge
congratulations to the authors you see
here how the simulation output depends
on the number of iterations more
iterations means that we redo the
calculations over and over again and get
results closer to what would happen in
real life at the cost of more
computational time however as you see we
can get close to the real solution with
even one iteration which is remarkable
in my own fluid simulation experiments
when I tried to solve the pressure field
using one to four iterations gave me a
result that's not only inaccurate but
singular which blows up the simulation
look at this on this axis you can see
how the fluid disturbances get more
pronounced as a response to a stronger
magnetic field and in this direction you
see how the effect of surface tension
smooths out these shapes what a
visualization the information density in
this example is just out of this world
and it is still both informative and
beautiful if only I could tell you how
many times I have to remake each of the
figures in pursuit of this I can only
imagine how long it took to finish this
one Bravo
and if all that's not enough for you to
fall out of your chair get this
it is about lee bo huang the first
author of this paper i became quite
curious about his other works and have
found exactly zero of them this was his
first paper my goodness and of course it
takes a team to create such a work so
congratulations to all three authors
this is one heck of a paper check it out
in the video description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time